simon a acheté un triplex io9 il ya
quelques années pour établir le montant
de ces taxes municipales
un évaluateur engagés par la ville j'ai
mesuré la superficie de son immeuble
l'évaluateur se trompe il rajoute 2 qui
mit à la façade du triplex résultats
simon payent plus de taxes foncières
qu'il ne devrait près de 1000 dollars en
trop depuis sept ans simon peut-il être
remboursés nous avons consulté deux
avouac là la réponse est non même si
l'évaluateur de la ville s'est trompé on
ne peut pas le tenir responsable de son
erreur et ce même si les mesures ne
figure pas sur son compte et que simon
ne peut pas savoir qu'il ya eu une
erreur incroyable mais c'est pourtant à
lui de s'assurer que les mesures qui
détermine la valeur de sa maison sans
exacte et le seul moment où il peut
contester et dans les quatre premiers
mois du nouveau rôle d'évaluation
triennal
conclusion si vous payer plus de taxes
que votre voisin demandé à la direction
de l'évaluation de votre municipalité de
vous fournir ces mesures